للمره الثالثه يختار الاتراك رئيسهم
بواسطه الاختراع المباشر قبل ذلك كان يتم
انتخاب الرئيس بواسطه البرلمان بعد
انتخابات برلمانيه لكن في عام 2007 وبعد
ازمه رافقت انتخاب الرئيس السابق عبد الله
جولف جرى تعديل دستوري تم بموجبه الموافقه
على انتخاب الرئيس بشكل مباشر من قبل
الشعب في عام 2014 جرت اولى الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في البلاد وفاز فيها الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان بنسبه تجاوزت 51% وكان حينها
منافسه الرئيسي اكمل الدين احسان اوغلو
الامين العام الاسبق لمنظمه التعاون
الاسلامي في عام 2018 جرت انتخابات مبكره
وفاز فيها ايضا الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
بنسبه تجاوزت 52% وكان حينها منافسه
الابرز محرم انجا مرشح حزب الشعب الجمهوري
في انتخابات الرابعه عشر من مايو حصل
الرئيس اردوغان على ما نسبته
49.5% من اصوات الناخبين وحصل منافسه
الرئيسي كمال كلجدار اوغلو على ما نسبته
44.8
ولان ايا من المرشحين لم يحصل على خمسين
زائد واحد وهي النسبه المطلوبه للفوز
بمنصب الرئيس جرت جوله اعاده هذه الجوله
هي الاولى من نوعها في تاريخ تركيا وهي
التي ستحدد الرئيس الثالث عشر للجمهوريه
التركيه